-Looking good, Kev.
Kev, what do you have there?
'Cause I have it here, as well,
I believe.
-Oh, this here?
-Yeah.
-This is actually
a very smooth taste
of my new tequila called
Gran Coramino.
It's a cristalino.
If you don't know, cristalino is
a clear reposado, which is why I
decided to do it.
But it's a very good tequila.
My tequila.
I gave you a taste as well.
Enjoy. Enjoy.
[ Laughter ]
Taste the goddam--Taste it!
-Tequila's not one of those
things you just throw down.
-Mine is.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I kinda prepare myself?
-Taste the damn tequila, Jimmy!
-I know, but hold on a second.
Like, we gotta be in the thing,
where --
-No, we don't.
-Like, where are we?
-No, we don't. Well, right now?
-No, I mean, like what would we
normally do to have this?
-Well, I would probably be
talking.
I would be having a conversation
about what I did last night.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Deep voice ] Wow. Wow.
-Huh?
See that?
-It changed -- Look,
my voice is different.
-It's different, right?
-It changed me.
-You want it to have a little
bite but it doesn't have a bite.
It's very smooth.
-[ Normal voice ] It's smooth.
-How do you get --
I -- I have so many questions.
-How do I get smooth?
-No, no, no, I know.
You've always been smooth.
-Want me to answer that?
-No, no,
you've always been smooth.
-How do I get smooth.
This guy.
This guy, how do I get smooth?
This guy, all of a sudden.
But how do you get involved
with a tequila company?
-I'm a tequila lover.
I have been for a long time,
and --
-But you've gotta put a lot
of work into this stuff
if you wanna
put your name on it.
-Well, it took me about four --
four to five years
to develop it.
And I didn't want to just do it
with anybody.
So, I went and found
who I call basically the --
the King of tequila, a guy named
Juan Beckmann, right?
And what he is,
and is responsible
for so much growth in the space.
His distribution pipeline,
the development, like,
he's done it right.
So I went to him, I told him
I wanted to partner with him,
and I wanted to make
what I could consider
the best version
of a tequila for me.
And we stumbled on a cristalino,
and I wasn't happy
until it was right.
You know, if it's not right,
then it's not for me.
It has to be a part
of my lifestyle.
And we cracked the code.
-Is that one of your things
that you do?
You just work with great people.
-Yes.
-The best people.
-Well, you've gotta outsource
people that you can grow with.
I'm all about relationships.
You're a relationship.
We've grown over the course
of years, right?
And me coming on your show
isn't something where you worry
'cause you know I got
your back, you got mine.
That's a great relationship.
[ Light laughter ]
It should be like that.
Why'd you laugh?
That wasn't a joke.
[ Laughter ]
It should be like that.
-It is like that.
I mean, I got your back,
but you know.
-I always get your back.
I love you.
How's the fam?
-Well, I mean,
they're good now.
You didn't -- You didn't call on
Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
-You changed your number.
-That's true.
I did change my number.
But you still have
my hotmail address.
[ Laughter ]
-Hotmail.
-Yeah, you don't hotmail.
-You know what I saw?
I saw a video of the baby --
oh, no, not the baby.
The baby is one, right?
-My baby is --
my youngest is two.
-Two.
And then the other one,
the 4-year-old is the one --
-Yes, Kenzo.
-Kenzo.
-Your wife was in the car
and she goes,
"Kenzo,
do an impression of Daddy."
-Oh, my goodness.
-You see this?
-He's spot-on.
He's got me down.
-Let me show everyone --
I wanna show everyone
a clip of this.
-He really does have me down.
-Tell me how Daddy talks.
-He talks like, "What?
What you doin' there?
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
One, two, three, okay."
-What else does he say?
He say, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Dude, that is so cute.
So cute.
Dude, it's so good.
He should open for you, man.
He should come out
and do an early show.
Do an afternoon show.
-He's such an [bleep]
-No!
[ Laughter ]
Come on, that's --
-That impression --
that impression.
-You did not like
that impression of you.
-He attacked me.
You saw what he did.
[ Laughter ]
He attacked me.
No, such a good impression.
And he also can do me
coming out on stage.
He'll go -- He does my, like,
"What's going on, everybody?
How y'all feel?"
-He does that.
-He has it down pat.
-Can I ask you about going
onstage, 'cause I know you're --
tonight, actually,
you're leaving tonight.
You're going to do a show
with Chris Rock.
-Yes, at the Barclays.
-At the Barclays.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, two of the best.
-Yes.
-Two of the best to ever do it.
But then you were at the Garden
the other night.
By the way, I would say,
every show is sold out.
Beyond sold out.
And you went to the Garden
the other day,
and who came out to open
for you and Chris Rock?
-Uh, you know,
we were very lucky
to have the relationships
that we have.
Dave Chappelle decided
to come out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at this.
But then --
-That's a goat.
That's a goat.
-Yeah.
Now, how did --
how did a goat get on stage
and who brought the goat?
-Well, basically the idea
came because I was like,
"You know, Chris, we should
do some shows together.
How about we just do New York
and Jersey together?"
Chris was like, "Cool."
And I said, "Dude, if we do it,
Chappelle's gonna come."
And Rock was like,
"Yeah, no, he'll come."
And I said, "It'll be like,
the biggest night in history
if he comes."
So, then I told Dave, I said,
"Hey, man, I'm going to gift
Chris a goat
at the end of the show."
He said, "What do you mean?"
I said, "What do you mean,
what do I mean?
I'm gonna go get a goat."
He said, "How you gonna
get a goat?"
I said, "I'm Kevin Hart.
What do you mean,
how am I going to get a goat?
I can get a goat."
[ Laughter ]
-How do you get a goat?
-What do you mean,
how do you get a goat?
You don't know
how to get a goat?
You call the goat guy.
-Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Call the goat person.
-There's a goat guy.
You call him, tell him I need
a goat, bring the goat.
And next thing you know,
you got the goat.
So, we get the goat.
We get the goat,
but I hid the goat from Chris.
I didn't want him to see it.
Dave knew about the goat.
And at the end of the show,
an amazing show,
we all come back on stage,
and we're saying good night.
And I said, "Chris --"
You know, you guys don't know,
Chris is a mentor,
friend, inspiration.
But he's a large part
of the reason that I am
where I am today in my career
just from his advice,
his insight, et cetera.
And he's my G.O.A.T.,
like, he's my guy.
And I wanted him to feel
that and experience
the world of understanding
of how I feel about him
in front of that audience.
So I gave him the goat
and I said,
"Please give my guy
his flowers."
And they stood up,
screamed, loved.
He almost cried.
He almost broke down and cried
on stage, 'cause he --
-Chris did?
-Yeah, yeah, Chris did, man,
it was a real moment.
Like, you don't see
that in our culture enough.
You don't see us share
the spotlight, and us --
us show alignment in,
you know, the --
in the space of "there doesn't
have to just be one."
Right?
Like, there's been this thing of
"it can only be one guy,
or one funny guy at the top."
-Yeah, greatest of all time.
-And it's not the case.
There's so many.
There's so much talent,
and we should all celebrate
each other more.
And that's what that moment
was about,
it was about celebrating
my brother.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love that.
-Quest was there.
-Questlove was there.
I was like,
"Dude, how do you top --
how do you top Dave Chappelle?
How do you top Chris Rock?
How do you top Kevin Hart?"
You bring out the goat, and how
did the goat top everything?
-Well.
-[ Laughs ]
-The goat, uh, the goat took
a [bleep] on stage.
-There you go, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
Dude, Questlove said it was
the funniest thing he ever saw.
-It was not
planned either, Quest.
That's the one thing
I didn't think about.
In my mind, I said, "The goat's
going to come out,
do a tight two minutes."
[ Laughter ]
But instead, he [bleep]
on Chris' shoes.
[ Laughter ]
He destroyed Chris' shoes.
Chris had on some white
moon boots and that goat --
that goat got him.
-Moon boots.
-Chris just jumped in,
"You gotta be --!"
You know Chris, he's like --
[ Laughter ]
"The [bleep] goat [bleep]!"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry for cursing, but it's
the Gran Coramino.
-I know, yeah.
-Sorry.
-You have so
many things going on.
"Hart to Heart" is your show
on Peacock.
You do a great job with that.
-Thank you, man.
-I know you probably
got inspired by --
who's your favorite
people -- interviewers?
-I did. I did.
I really did.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, who's your favorite --
-I'm telling you, I did.
-Yeah, you did.
People you admire,
talk show hosts.
-Yeah.
-And you took advi--
You did what they are doing,
and you did it.
-You know what?
I'm a sponge, and I soak up what
I can from those I'm around.
I've been around a lot
of great hosts.
And for me to now
have a talk show
where I'm able to duplicate
what I've seen, right?
And really put that
to work is special.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you about to bring out
a goat, maybe?
-No. No.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know who it was?
I shouldn't have to tell you
who it was.
-Of course I do.
-Conan.
Me and Conan --
[ Laughter ]
Me and Conan, we spent a lot --
-We're already in commercial.
We already went to commercial.
-But you should know
about my relationships.
-[ Laughs ]
But you do that,
but then we had --
Mark Wahlberg is coming on.
You have a movie with Mark
called "Me Time."
-Called "Me Time," yes.
-About a man who says,
"hey, you know,
I need a little me time
right now," and --
and hooks up with his old buddy.
-Yeah.
-Who is Mark Wahlberg.
-Yes.
-Who ruins your life.
-Well, that's
a very good breakdown.
[ Laughter ]
You know, look, it's not about
your life being ruined.
It's about your past
becoming your present,
and you not being prepared
for your present.
I play a character who just
needs some time to himself.
He hasn't had alone time.
He's a dedicated father,
and his kids have kind of
taken over his life.
And because he's been consumed
in that, he forgot how to live.
And my best friend of old
comes back
and shows me how to live again.
But what he shows me,
it creates nothing
but turmoil and problems for me.
It's a comedy adventure,
Mark Wahlberg, myself,
Regina Hall.
-I will say there's a tortoise
involved in this movie.
-There is a tortoise.
-And it's very, very funny.
-Do you like tortoises?
-Yeah.
-I got to know tortoises
very well doing this movie.
I spent a lot of time with them.
-You got a goat guy,
you got a tortoise guy.
-I got every guy.
-You got every kind of guy.
What do you want?
-Tell me what you want,
I can get it for you right now.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk about
another big movie you have.
-Okay. 'Cause I got a lot.
-We both have kids.
You do have a lot.
-But "DC League of Super-Pets."
-You better have brought it up.
-That's right.
It comes out this Friday.
-This Friday, yes.
-Unbelievable cast.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dwayne Johnson, John Krasinski,
Kate McKinnon, Keanu Reeves.
Should we set it up?
Let's go to commercial, and
I'll set up when we come back.
-Go to commercial, let's set
it up when we come back.
-'Cause then, I also want
to talk about the tortilla slap.
-Okay, we gotta do that.
By the way, by the way,
I got your back.
Go.
-More with Kevin Hart
after the break.
Stick around everybody.
You've got my back?